how does a screenwriter pique the
interest of studios and decision makers
I think screenwriters stand their best
chance of really getting noticed by
knowing what the business needs so it's
not coming in talking about how
passionate you are about the script it's
talking and speaking in a way that
answers to the needs of the production
company the producer the studio etc it's
there are tried and tested genres that
are just they they just nail what the
business lives on and if you're if a
young writer wants to come into the
business and really just get their
emails answered get the phone calls
returned it's being able to speak about
their project and have it answer to
those things it's it's gonna be saying
I'm writing a family film about this I'm
writing a film about this and it's a
very quick point it's not it's you know
never coming-of-age stories it's never
dramas it's it's happier films it's it's
the kinds of films you see on a Redbox
machine that's what Hollywood needs to
stay in business and so if you're coming
to the table bringing opportunities for
Hollywood to continue staying in
business they're gonna pay attention to
you so if you have that indie drama
coming of age of let's say like a male
rebel who's trying to find you know
answers to life save that for your own
weekend project yeah and never at any
point am I saying
don't write dramas don't write comedies
don't write the coming-of-age story if
you have a fantastic idea for a movie I
think a writer should hold on just hold
on to it wait like get the commercial
scripts out first get a reputation of
being our screenwriter who can deliver
what the system needs who can write
quickly who can write well who can write
within budget and get a couple of actual
paid gigs and you'll get them if you go
in the opposite way saying I know what
Hollywood wants they want this they want
these very deep dramas coming-of-age
dramas and forcing them to do that it's
not you're not going to get noticed but
if you come in giving them what they
want which are like tween girl
films or Christmas movies with dogs
women in peril thrillers these kinds of
things
Hollywood pays attention to you and once
you are writing those and once you're
getting noticed for that work then you
have a collection of contacts and you
can say I have an interesting idea could
this work and then you can present those
you